fait ça c'est de la part de tous les
commerçants à qui tu as pourri la
vitrine
ses carreaux les 42 qui bat de vous je
mets faire les carreaux monsieur bah ça
se voit c'est tout crade
oh
quoi
vous laver les carreaux
bakkour qui se reprend mais moi j'ai
demandé à personne ne me l'avait l'état
bon c'est pas c'est pas chez moi je sais
pas où vous voulez aller mais c'est pas
chez moi là c'est pas chez vous ici
[Musique]
ici je suis chez moi mais vous vous
serez pas la paix mais caron un rôle ah
oui
bonjour enfin un ping pong vous avez mis
ko
bah comment ai je prend une raclée je
mets les lourds je sais je fais ça je
compte bien terminer et voilà accord
tiens c'est que j'ai été obligé de vous
le comté avait pas du tout monsieur
kouakou dépens de compter jusqu'à s'auto
sur ma vitrine moi sinon je l'appelle
défilent tout de suite moi j'avais
décrit ce que ça veut dire ça vous
suivez des soldats partout vous venez de
me dire finie semeta poudre à klein mais
monsieur vous venez de jeter un seau
d'eau dans la vitrine d'un bug de quel
droit le parce que ses salles fétiche
mais si ça peut vous faire que ce soit
salle est ce que je vais demander
quelque chose non alors vous prenez
votre matériel qui vous partez avec on
met ça c'est pas bien pour les petits
artisans
non mais oh j'arrive chez vous avec une
caisse de vin je vous la dépouille je
vous dis je voulais monter à l'étagé
maintenant vous me payez vous allez me
dire je faisais pas commander du vin bon
ben moi je fais pas commander nettoyer
mais carreau voilà c'est tout et si je
vous recommande du vin
qu'est ce que vous avez fait ça ma femme
elle arrive vous allez lui axé les gars
là savent les faire plaisir à les
basques à vous touchez pas la hache
juste le goût de touche n'est pas là du
tout
vous touchez pas la grèce un rôle dans
la série alors vous essayez ça s'il vous
plaît que tu touche j'appelle les flics
moi d'accord un nom mais quand même et
c'est eux qui vont me régler non
non ça suffit
[Musique]
à leicester